simplifica 3 por la raíz principal de
500 x cúbico y lo que vamos a hacer aquí
es separar lo que está adentro del
radical en los términos que son
cuadrados perfectos y que podemos
extraer del radical y lo demás lo que
sobre lo dejaremos dentro del radical
también hay que recordar que cuando nos
referimos a la raíz principal este signo
de radical aquí nos referimos a la raíz
cuadrada positiva de un número veamos
entonces si podemos separar 500 x cúbica
en algo que sea cuadrado perfecto y algo
que no va a ser cuadrado perfecto pues
para empezar ni 500 ni x cúbica son
cuadrados perfectos cuando haya duda
empiezas a sacar factores primos de esto
para poder encontrar aquellos factores
que son cuadrados perfectos entonces 500
lo podemos factorizar como 5% y aquí
podríamos ver que 100 ya es el cuadro
perfecto es 10 al cuadrado pero si no
notaremos eso podemos seguir extrayendo
factores 100
es 2 por 50/50 es la multiplicación de 2
por 25 y 25 la multiplicación de 5 por 5
y aquí es donde ya podemos ver que aquí
tenemos dos por dos tenemos dos al
cuadrado y aquí tenemos cinco por 55 al
cuadrado tienes 10 por 10 y 2 al
cuadrado por 5 al cuadrado de cualquier
las dos maneras puede separar esto y x
cúbica x cúbica se puede separar x
cúbica que tenemos aquí claramente lo
podemos separar como x cuadrada por
equis hemos separado x cúbica en algo
que es un cuadro perfecto y algo que no
es un cuadrado perfecto que escribamos
entonces este término que está dentro
del radical esto es igual a 3 por la
raíz deja un espacio aquí 3 por la raíz
de 500 que puede escribir como 5% y 100
que es el cuadro perfecto de 10
lo puedo escribir como 10 al cuadrado no
tengo que hacer esto que hicimos aquí
pero esto te ayudaría a reconocer que
esto es 4 por 25 los dos son cuadrados
perfectos así que esto es igual a 3 por
la raíz de 10 al cuadrado por 5 500 del
10 al cuadrado por 5 esto de aquí los
pinos como 10 algo por 5 y x cúbica x
cúbica que puede escribir como x
cuadrada por x x cuadrada por equis y
déjame extender el signo radical hasta
acá y esto es lo mismo que usando las
propiedades básicas de los exponentes
porque bueno cuando estamos tomando una
raíz
estamos aplicando propiedades de
exponentes fraccionarios así es que esto
de aquí es lo mismo esto es igual a 3
por la raíz principal de 10 al cuadrado
déjame hacerlo así con este color por la
raíz principal de 5 por la raíz
principal de x cuadrada y por la raíz
principal de x y ahora podemos
simplificar esto como aquí tenemos la
raíz principal de 100 que es 10 10 de la
raíz principal de 100 menos 10 también
es raíz de siempre estamos solo tomando
la raíz principal así es que la raíz
principal de 100 es 10 -cinco no es un
cuadro perfecto así es que dejamos este
término simplemente como la raíz
cuadrada de 5 ahora x cuadrada aquí
mucha gente tú estarías tentado a decir
bueno la raíz de x cuadrada es
simplemente equis pero no mucha atención
pero qué pasaría si x es un valor
negativo supongamos que x es un valor
negativo por ejemplo supongamos que x es
igual a menos 2 entonces al elevar x al
cuadrado esto nos va a dar 4 y aquí la
raíz
a la raíz principal de 4 esto es 2 pero
si hubiéramos tomado el valor de x
estaríamos tomando el valor de menos 2
pero como tenemos la raíz principal
tenemos que tomar el valor de x con
signo positivo es decir sin importarnos
si x es positivo o negativo para la raíz
principal siempre queremos la x con
signo positivo
esto es entonces el valor absoluto de x
esa es la cualidad de la raíz principal
y ahora esto simplifica recuerda que
como estamos aquí multiplicando una
serie de expresiones no importa en qué
orden tomamos el producto podemos
ordenarlos de tal manera que primero
tomamos los términos que tienen radical
y posteriormente los términos que no
tienen radical tenemos entonces 3 por 10
pueblo absoluto de x esto es 3 por 10
que es igual a 30 30 vuelvo a lo
absoluto de x30 por el valor absoluto de
x y esto multiplicado por raíz cuadrada
de 5 y por raíz cuadrada de x raíz
cuadrada
y aquí tenemos la raíz principal la raíz
cuadrada de 5 por la raíz cuadrada de x
esto lo podemos escribir como la raíz
cuadrada de 5 x aquí tienes el producto
de dos cosas elevada a la misma potencia
fraccionaria es lo mismo que tomar
primero el producto y después elevar
todo eso a la potencia fraccionaria
potencia fraccionario sacar raíz
cuadrada así es que esto se simplifica
finalmente como 30 por el valor absoluto
de x por la raíz cuadrada de 5x